like things were working good last week.
And then like a couple weeks ago,
there's been some increases in CPC and you didn't catch it.
And, and I've reviewed how to do that with some of you.
And all of a sudden your ads tank and you're like,
what, what's going on?
And you just, it's just a learning thing with Google.
You just gotta, you gotta just go, well, this is weird.
Gotta go back into the budget, gotta go back into here.
And then you start seeing these changes and you go, oh, okay.
What was $5 is now $11.
And you're like, all right, that makes sense.
So what would you recommend in a situation like that,
as far as like an action step for somebody like that?
And I don't know, let's say, I mean,
I can tell you this is,
let's say this is somebody that you've sold,
like you've actually sold the business owner.
I would just go to them and be honest with them and say,
Hey, my costs have doubled.
And you can explain it like Jeff did, you know,
Google's laid off 12,000 employees.
I think they're trying to make more money on ads,
or I don't know for sure, but my costs have doubled.
Are you comfortable if we bump up, you know,
our deal, you know, if not, that's fine.
But I just don't know if we're gonna be able
to get as many leads.
So I would just be honest in that situation.